مشاهدينا شكرا لخالد وانا ميسون عزام
احييكم والتغطيه مستمره للاحداث في
السودان البدايه مع اثار الحرب الدائره
رصدت منظمه الصحه العالميه مقتله 330 شخص
واصابه ثلاثه الافئتين اخرين جراء
الاشتباكات في السودان الصحه العالميه دعا
جميع الاطراف في السودان
للهدنه الانسانيه والسماح للمواطنين
بالحصول على الرعايه الطبيه كما اكدت
المنظمه انها ستجلب المزيد من التجهيزات
الطبيه لدى السماح بذلك مشيره الى النقص
الحاد في امدادات المياه والوقود في
المنشات الصحيه بالسودان نقابه اطباء
السودان قالت ان 52 مستشفى من اصل 74
متوقفه عن الخدمه
ان الصوره التي نشاهدها الان صوره جويه
لمطار الخرطوم طبعا نشاهد الدخان يتصاعد
اشتباكات كانت موجوده كان هناك ايضا قصف
في الفتره الاخيره على كل النوافيكم
بالمزيد حاله ورود المعلومات
طبعا مطار الخرطوم منذ بدء الاشتباكات كان
المركز الرئيس لهذه الحرب الدائره ما بين
الدعم السريع والجيش السوداني في حينها
ايضا تم التعرض لبعض الطائرات الخطوط
الجويه المختلفه منذ البدايه اوقفت العمل
والسفر من السودان والى السودان حتى
اشعار اخر وحتى الان نتحدث عن سته ايام لا
زالت الاشتباكات مستمره رغم الهدنه هناك
في هذه الهدنه اشتباكات
متقطعه ننتظر نرى التطورات الاخيره الدعم
السريع كانت قد اعلنت انها على استعداد
للدخول في هدنه جديده بمعنى اخر تمديد هذه
الهدنه وان تستمر خلال عيد الفطر
[موسيقى]
حرب تانيه دفعت النظام الصحيه في السودان
الى حافه الانهيار لتصبح الازمه ازمتين
تزيد من ماساه الشعب السوداني الذي اتخن
بالجراح في بلد لم يعرف الاستقرار التام
منذ عقود وهو الان ضحيه السيناريو الاسوا
ارقام صادمه لعدد المستشفيات التي اصبحت
خارج الخدمه في ذروه احتياج المواطنين لها
سبعون في المئه من المرافق الصحيه اوقفت
عن العمل او اجبرت على الاغلاق بحسب نقابه
اطباء السودان فمن اصل 74 مستشفى في
العاصمه والولايات التي تقع بالقرب من
مناطق الاشتباك يوجد 52 مستشفى منها اصبحت
خارج الخدمه تماما بعد الاشتباكات الاخيره
تسعه مستشفيات منها تعرضت القصف الشديد
وتسعه عشر مستشفى اخر تعرضت للاخلاء
القصري ما يعني وجود
مستشفى فقط في المنطقه تعمل بشكل كامل او
جزئي وهي الاخرى مهدده بالاغلاق في اي
لحظه بسبب انقطاع التيار الكهربائي
وانعدام الادويه وغياب الكوادر الصحيه
فهذه المرافق الطبيه تعمل بالحد الادنى من
الامكانيات والحد الاقصى من انعدام الامن
حولها
نظام الرعايه الصحيه في السودان يمكن ان
ينهر تماما تحتاج المستشفيات الى موظفين
اضافي وتحتاج الى امدادات اضافيه وتحتاج
الى امدادات دم اضافي هناك تقريبا هجوم
عسكري على عدد من المؤسسات الصحيه هناك
يعني هجوم على سيارات اسعاف وبها مرضى
وبها عاملين صحيين وعلى الرغم من تصاعد
التحذيرات الدوليه من كارثه انسانيه
وانهيار القطاع الصحي في البلاد الا ان
القتال لازال يتواصل في عاصمه السودانيه
ومدن اخرى
مشكله كبيره الناس على سبيله الناس ما
لاقي يعني حتى الموت الصحفي محلات
التجاريه
الجوفيه والمعاناه كبيره جدا درجه الحراره
مرتفعه وهي مياه برضو مش صالحه للشرب بغدر
ما هي ممكن يتم استخدامها في اشياء تانيه
مزيد معنا من مدينه مروي مراسل العربيه
نزار بوي اهلا بك نزار اخر المعلومات
المتوفره لديك تفضل
الامور هنا في مدينه مروي وفي الولايه
الشماليه هي الامور تمضي نحو الاستقرار
ونحو الهدوء هذا الهدوء جاء نتيجه لخروج
قوات الدعم
الاشتباكات في مدينه مروي بعد يومين كانت
فيها القوات المسلحه السودانيه الجيش
السوداني قد استخدم المدفعيه الثقيله
واستخدم ايضا الطائرات في مواجهه ما تبقى
من قوات الدعم السريعه التي كانت متمركزه
خلال ايام الماضيه داخل محيط
مروي وداخيل المطار الدولي الان الجيش
يتحدث عن ان لا وجود لقوات الدعم السريعه
في مروي وحتى في خارج حدود مروي وان
الامور الان تحت السيطره تماما وما
شاهدناه اليوم بان المواطنين بداوا في
حياتي بشكل تدريجي طيب نتحدث عن
الحركه في الشارع بعد قليل ولكن دعني اشير
الى نقطه مهمه لانه اثرنا هذا السؤال
سابقا فيما يتعلق بالمخاوف من عوده جديده
للدعم السريع وفي حينها اذكر نزار بانك
قلت وهدفي بدايات الازمه ان الجيش
منفتح على كل الخيارات ويستعد لكل
الخيارات هل لا زالت قضيه عوده الدعم
السريع الى مروي قائمه او لا انتهت كليا
حتى الان خطه الجيش تمضي وفق ما يقول
عسكريون
لبسط السيطره على المطار
وتامين حدود المطار وتامين كل المناطق في
شمال السودان وحتى الطرق المؤديه الى ام
درمان هذه يبدو انها ملامح السلطه المقبله
الحديث عن عوده الدعم السريع من عدمه الى
هذه المنطقه تبقى
رهن تكهنات
بالمرحله هي مرحله حرب الجيش الدعم السريع
الاوضاع كلها الان تترحل وتمضي وفقه
سيناريوهات لا يعرف احد الا تمضي هذه
المعلنات الوضع معقد بعض الشيء البلاد تمر
بمرحله حرب ولا احد يمتلك تقديرات مؤكده
حول طبيعه من سيمضي نحو اي خطوه هل سياتي
الدعم السريع هل سيتقدم
هل سيضرب الجيش في مكان اخر هل ستنسحب
قوات الدعم السريع من الخرطوم هل ستواصل
القتال كل هذه الفرضيات تظل مطروحه بما ان
الحرب مستمره ولم تتوقع وكيفيه انتشار
الجيش السوداني في مروي اين يتمركز فقط في
القاعده وفي المطار ام في اماكن اخرى ربما
على حدود المدينه
في مدينه مروي توجد قياده الفرقه التاسعه
عشر بوشاه وهي فرقه عسكريه موزعه في هذه
المنطقه لها حدود مسؤوليه تنتشر في معظم
ارجاء هذه المحليه وارجاء ايضا الولايه
الشماليه
المناطق التي تنتشر فيها القوات المسلحه
مناطق تتعلق بحدود المطار بمداخل المطار
حتى بعض النقاط الاستكاديه هنا في مروي في
المدينه
وضعت كما عرفنا وكما فهمنا من القيادات
العسكريه
لمص حاله الاستقرار والطمانيين في نصوص
المواطنين الذين بداوا فعليا بالعوده الى
نمط حياتهم بشكل تدريجي وحتى الذين غادروا
المدينه عادوا اليها امس واليوم بشكل يبدو
يبدو انه استعداد لعيد الفطر المبارك لكن
على الجميع بالخير باذن عندي سؤال فقط
اخير فيما يتعلق بالجانب العسكري لانك كنت
متواجد داخل المطار اظهرت لنا صور كثيره
فيما يتعلق
بالاستهدافات الخسائر الماديه استهداف
من زاويه معينه ولكن ايضا في الايام
السابقه كنت تتحدث انه بعد السيطره
الكامله على هذا المطار والقاعده تقوم
قوات الجيش بعمليه جرد لما حدث متى يمكن
لنا ان نسمع الى اللائحه النهائيه لهذا
الجرد حول الخسائر داخل هذا المطر
المطار كبير بعض الشيء نتحدث عن 18 كيلو
متر مربع مساحه ليست بالسهله وليست
القصيره هي مسافه ممتده في هذه المحليه
قوات المهندسين التابعه للقوات المسلحه
السودانيه او السلاح المهندسين
بدات منذ امس في
التعامل مع الاجسام المتفجره وغيرها
منفجره وتعمل على نصف الضرر ومعرفه
الاليات
نتيجه الضرر هل هو ضرر كلي هل هو عطل كلي
هذه الامور تحتاج الى بعض الوقت ولم نتاكد
حتى الان بان الجيش له ميقات معلوم عبره
سيخبر الراي العامه والاعلام عن حجم
الخسائر او اضطراب الذي تعرض له المطار
لكن هذه الامور تمضي والجيش قال بانه يسعى
لحصر كل ما حدث وكل ما نتج في مطار بدوي
في القاعده الع سكريه الان يمكننا باختصار
الحديث عن ما ذكرته قبل قليل من عوده
الحياه الى النمط الطبيعي اذا مصحه تعبير
ولكنه مغلف ايضا بايام العيد والاستعداد
للعيد تفضل نزار
نعم الوضع الان تحديدا وضع المدنيين ووضع
السكان خلال الثلاثه ايام الماضيه كان
الخوف وكانت توتر هو من يسيطر وهو من يطوق
وهو من يسود المدينه والمحليه والولايه
الشماليه على وجه العموم لكن بعد الانباء
التي تاكدت بسيطره القوات المسلحه على
المطار وعلى القاعده
الاخبار
وتناقلت وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي هدوء
الامور وابتعاد قوات الدعم السريعه مروي
وعن حدود المحليه جنوبا بدا المواطنون
يستعدون خاصه الذين غادروا هذه المدينه
المنوي باتجاه مناطق وقرى اكثر امنا اعاد
اليوم لاحظنا بصوره واضحه دائما نسوق
الرئيس الذي يمثل عصب المركز الاقتصادي في
المحليه بدات تدب فيه الحياه من جديد حركه
الشراء حركه البيع حتى شرطه المرور الان
تنتشر في الطرقات لتسهيل
تنقل المواطنين والسيارات والراتبين الوضع
المدني يمضي نحو التعافي هذا ما يمكن ان
نختصره ونخرجه في عنوان عريض وكهرباء في
مياه وكهرباء
نعم المياه خدمات الكهرباء
في فترات مختلفه لكن الان توجد احياء
كثيره تتمتع بخطه المياه بخدمه الكهرباء
خدمات الاتصالات ايضا متوفره المواد
الغذائيه متوفره
المواطنين هنا يعينون بعضهم البعض يساندون
بعضهم البعض روح التكافل موجوده وسط
مواطني هذه المحليه في شمال السودان هنا
محليه شكرا من مدينه مروي كان معنا مراسل
العربيه نزار بقداوي شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
بحث وزير الخارجيه السعوديه الامير فيصل
بن فرحان ونظيره البريطانيه جيمس كليبرلي
بحثا تطورات الاوضاع في السودان وذلك خلال
اتصال هاتفي دعا الوزيران الى وقف اطلاق
النار والتصعيد العسكري وانهاء العنف
وحمايه المدنيين وتوفير الممرات الامنه
للعمليات الانسانيه
من جانبيه دانا مستشار الامن القومي
الامريكيه جاك سلفا استمرار العنف السودان
لليوم السادس داعيا طرفي الصراع لوقف
الاعمال العدائيه فورا مؤكدا على تاييده
للتطلعات الشعب السوداني في الانتقال
الديمقراطي السلمي
المزيد معنا من باريس الكاتب الصحفي محمد
الاسباتي اهلا بك سيد محمد بدايه قراءتك
للمشهد الان وخاصه بعد اعلان الدعم السريع
قبوله
لتبديد الهدنه لتشمل ايام الاعياد كامله
مساء الخير هذا الامر متوقع طبعا
ذكرته على شاشتكم امس وامس الاول بان
حالات الهدنه ستتمدد
بعد ان كانت ست ثلاث ساعات تحولت الى 24
ساعه
ليومين اليوم الثالث طب تم الاعلان عن
تمديد الهدنه
24 ساعه والان هنالك حديث عن هدنه لمده
ثلاثه ايام وهنالك حديث عن اربعه او خمسه
ايام وهذا الامر متوقع ما ان تبدا عمليات
او او تحديد اجال زمنيه للهدنه وستتسح هذه
الفترات الى الوصول الى
هدنه بمراقبه
دوليه او اقليميه تحديد عدم تحرك القوات
وبالتالي الترتيب لاجراء مفاوضات في
الغالب اتوقع بنهايه هذه الهدنه ان تبدا
مفاوضات غير مباشره بين الطرفين هنالك ضغط
الدولي قبل قليل كان هنالك حديث لمتحدث
باسم وزيره الخاريه الفرنسيه قالت ان نزلت
الخارجي الفرنسيه تبذل
تخوض حوار
يضم الامم المتحده والاتحاد الافريقي
وايجاد والمملكه العربيه السعوديه ومصر
والامارات وانه خلال هذا اليوم سيتم
الاتفاق على خطوات عمليه هذا يدل على ان
هنالك تحرك دولي على نطاق واسع
لدفع الفريقين
الجنرال الحرب
قائد الانقلاب البرهان وقائد مليش الدعم
السريع الحميدي الى
تمديد وقف اطلاق النار والجلوس الى طاوله
التفاوض
الحراك النشط السياسي على مستوى دولي
واقليمي ان كان ينعكس على الارض دعني
انتقل لمراسل العربيه من الخرطوم سالم
الهاشمي لينقل لنا الوضع الميداني سالم
نعم الان وقبل لحظات كان هناك سماع لمدافع
وكذلك مضادات لطائرات هنا في منطقه في
ضاحيه كافوري وكذلك
في جهه
حله حمد وايضا في منطقه
جسر شنبات الرابط بين بحري
واندرمان تتجدد الاشتباكات الان هذا
الانوي لصوت مضاد للطائرات هنا في منطقه
بحري
وتتجدد هذه الاشتباكات منذ بدايه هذا
اليوم وقد كانت هناك
هجمات جويه من الجيش السوداني على المواقع
التي تتمركز فيها قوات الدعم السريع هذه
او هذا اليوم يقبله ان هذه الهدنه
لم تعد موجوده بهذه الهجمات وبتكرار هذه
الهجمات حتى هذه اللحظه الان هناك في
الاجواء طيران او لا حربي او لا
لا
وهناك تصاعد لدخان كثيف من منطقه الخرطوم
كذلك
او توحيد مطار الخرطوم في هذه الاثناء
ايضا نسمع هذه الطلقات بين الفن والاخرى
برصاص وايضا لمدافع ثقيله وخفيفه واحيانا
مضادات للطائرات كما كان قبل قليل طيب
دعني اعود لضيفي الكاتب صاحبي محمد
الاسباط للتعليق على ما يحدث على الارض
ان كانت الاشتباكات متقطعه ولكنها موجوده
وذلك قبل ان تنتهي الهدنه الاولى ونحن
نتحدث عن هدنه قادمه من المؤمن ان تكون
ربما طويله خلال العيد او اكثر من ذلك
بكثير هل يمكن اعتبار هذه اشارات على انه
لا هذه الهدنه ولا غيرها ستستمر ام انه لا
هذه ربما الضرب ات الاخيره ضربات استباقيه
ما قبل الهدنه وربما ما قبل الهدوء
هو واضح من خلال
الهدنه الاولى التي كانت يوم
يوم الاثنين والهدنه الثانيه يوم الثلاثاء
او الهدنه الثالثه يوم الاربعاء وبدا واضح
ان هنالك ازمه في التسلسل القيادي لدى
قائد
الانقلاب وقواته ولد غايه مليشه الدعم
السريع وقواته وربما ايضا ان هنالك يعني
مشكله او ازمه مهنيه في وفق القدرات اداره
المعارك ربما هنالك خلافات بين الغاز
الميدانيين وبعض قياداتهم العليا وربما
ايضا ان هنالك ازمه تواصل او ازمه اتصالات
لانه في كل حالات الهدنه يتم خرق الهدنه
في حين ان الغائدين الغائدين الانقلاب
وقيديه الحرب يعدلان ملء اصواتهم بانهما
ملتزمان بالهدنه من الساعه كذا الى الساعه
كذا ولكن اثناء هذه الفتره يتم خرق الهدنه
واضح ان هنالك اشكالات واضح ايضا انه
هنالك
اتفهم الخيارات التي وضعتها لما يحدث
باعتبار ان هناك نوع من التناقض او الفراغ
ما بين التصريحات الكلاميه وما يحدث على
الارض ولكن استخدام الطائرات واستخدام
المضادات يعني انه القرار ياتي من قيادات
نحن لا نتحدث عن اسلحه خفيفه هنا بهذا
الاطار
طبعا من يغرر
تسير الطيران هو قائد ميداني غير الميداني
لسلاح الطيران انا قلت لك ان القيادات
الميدانيه هنالك بعض الغيدانيه لا تتفق مع
قيادتها العليا وهنالك بعض الغيات
الميدانيه ترى ان على سبيل المثال القوات
المسلحه هنالك احاديث حتى سرب بعضها لدى
قاده غاده في القيادات العليا الادنى
الوسيطه ضد هي ضد اي هدنه وهذا معلن
اعلنوه مرارا وتكرارا وهنالك
ما يتم
بهدف هنالك توهم من منذ ان بدات الحرب
قائد الانقلاب يتوهم انه يستطيع ان يقضي
على الدعم السريع وقواته في خلال 48 ساعه
وقائد الدعم السريع يتوهم انه يستطيع ان
يقضي على الجيش
وقواته في اقل من
48 ساعه هنالك توهم وهنالك تضخم للذات
وهنالك يعني دقائق تولدت طبعا طوال
السنوات الماضيه
بالاضافه الى ان هنالك تباين في طريقه
اداره المعركه هنالك بعض القاده يرون ان
المعركه في مسار واحد منذ اليوم الاول حتى
اليوم الاخير وهنالك غاده يعني يميلون الى
التكتيكات والمعارك المرحليه معارك بعد
معاركه وساحر بعد ساحه والاسباب كثيره
متعدده واضافه الى كما ذكرت لك هنالك ازمه
اتصالات كما هو معلوم ان الاثنين يعتمدون
على
اتصالات امنه او فارتها
روسيا واسرائيل والبرهان يعتمد على
هذا الكلام سيد محمد اذا ما صح هذا الكلام
بالفعل وكان هناك نوع من الترهل او
الانشقاقات داخل كل جسم من الاجسام
المتحاربه للجسمين الرئيسيين طبعا قوى
الحريه تغيير تقول انه استمرار المعارك
سيؤدي الى تدخل اقليمي واسع باي اطار
وعملنا تحدث هنا
لا اريد التدخل الاقليمي بدا اوغل طويلا
عميقا في في هذه المعركه وهذا لا يحتاج
الى ان تقوله هو الحريه والتغيير هذا يعني
التدخل الاقليمي والتدخل الدولي في هذه
الحرب بدا واضحا منذ اليوم الثاني يعني
واساله بضع واضح منذ اليوم الثاني
ولا يخفى على اي بصيره يعني
هنالك علاقات قديمه تربط قائدي
الحرب في الخرطوم
بالحيط الاقليمي
وبالمحيط الدولي كما هو معلوم النفق جلبها
الجيش السوداني الى السودان منذ 2018
وترتبط بعلاقات وثيقه مع
غيروا من هاي ولكن يبدو يبدو سيدي انه
الحريه والتغيير عندما تتحدث عن نقطه
التدخل الاقليمي تتحدث ان يكون بشكل اوسع
وربما بشكل اوضح من من مصلحته هذه الفوضى
في السودان ان كان على المستوى الداخلي
البعض يقول فلول النظام ولكن على المستوى
الاقليمي من من مصلحته ان يكون السودان
فيه مثل هذه الازمات والاشتباكات والفوضى
باختصار لو سمحت
طبعا هناك دول عديده في المنطقه يعني تريد
ان يظل يستمر السودان ضعيفا ليس الهدف
الحرب والوصول الى الى نتيجه الهدف اضعاف
السودان لاسباب كثيره جدا السودان دوله
كبيره ودوله غنيه ودوله ثريه تمتاز بثروات
لديها ساحل استراتيجي مهم جدا على البحر
الاحمر لدي حدود مع عشر دول هي يمكن ان
تكون قلب للتجاره افريقيا في المستقبل
المتصله والمنظور هي يمكن ان تكون ان تكون
الحل الجزري لازمه الغذاء في العالم بما
تتوفر عليه من ارض زراعيه خصبه واثروه
حيوانيه
وبلد شاب نسبه الشباب تتجاوز
63% من سكان لاسباب كثيره جدا هنالك اسباب
كثيره تستهدف اضعاف هذه البلاد حتى تكون
يعني كل دوله عندما تاتي تبحث عن مصالحها
يكون من السهل ان تحصل على مصالحها لان
الدوره الدوره ضعيفه ودوله فاشله ودوله
هشه هذا امر متوقع ولكن السودانيين لماذا
لم ينتبهوا الى ان من يعني من ابسط حقوق
ومواجبات واستحقاقات الشعب عليهم سواء
كانوا قاده سياسيين او عسكريين ان
يساهموا في بناء بلدهم
محمد
ابتعد عن قضيه التدخلات الاقليميه وركز
على الداخل السوداني قال بانه تم جر هؤلاء
من قبل فلول النظام تم جر هؤلاء من قبل
جماعات معينه اليس هناك من رؤيه واسعه
وايمان بهذا البلد من قبل كل القيادات حتى
تتجر بهذه الطريقه
هذه البلاد وتعطيلها وتاخيرها ولكن من
المؤكد ان السودانيين الذين بعد حاله بعد
حاله ثوره استمرت 30 سنه في عهد المخلوع
عمر البشير وتمكنوا من ازاحته بوسائل
سلميه ومدنيه لا عنفيه يستطيعون ان يسقطوا
اي نظام ديكتاتوري او عسكري او الشمولي
يريد ان يفرض عليهم بقوه السلاح والنار
السلطه هذا امر انا اجيب
منه والتاريخ يؤكده ويثبته طيب وهذا يدفعه
للتساؤل عن دور المكون المدني الان في هذه
اللحظه وامكانيه ان تكون هناك
اراده حقيقيه لما قالت قوى الحريه
والتغيير بتشكيل كتله مدنيه صلبه ومتحده
ضد الحرب وما الدور الذي يمكن ان تقوم به
ولكن تسمح لي ان اعود الى مراسل العربيه
في الخرطوم سالم الهاشمي اللي طلعنا عن
على اي جديد سالم
[موسيقى]
طيب على كل معنى مدثر محمد احمد وهو صحفي
ايضا من الخرطوم من الجنوب اهلا بك مدثر
هل لك ان تعطينا اي معلومات لديك جديده
حول التطورات الميدانيه
الوضع الميداني حتى الان في منطقه جنوب
الخرطوم لا توجد اي خروقات بالهدنه
الخروقات تركزت خلال فتره الظهيره في
منطقه وسط الحكومه منطقه محيط القياده
العامه كما ذكر الزميل
سالم قبل قليل اليكم وفي مناطق ام درمان
ومنطقه بحري هذه هي المناطق التي تركز
فيها خروقات الهدنه
الان هناك اشتباكات وهناك اصوات لبعض
داخل منطقه
المحيط القياده العامه ومنطقه مطار
الخرطوم ولكن في منطقه جنوب الخرطوم لا
توجد اي اشتباكات على منطقه شرق النيل
ومنطقه منطقه جبره منطقه
شوبا شرق وسوبغ هذه المناطق لا توجد فيها
اي خلقات هذه المناطق استغلتها استغلها
المواطنين في عمليات النزوح الى
الخروج الى خارج ولايه الخرطوم في هذا ما
يتعلق بالوضع على الارض في منطقه جنوب
ودعنا نتعرف على الوضع في وسط العاصمه من
مراسل العربيه سالم الهاشمي سالم اخر
المعلومات لديك تفضل
اخر المعلومات هي انه ما زال الاشتباك هذا
متواصل تسمع مضادات للطائرات وكذلك مدافع
هنا في منطقه بحري بالمنطقه كافولي وكذلك
في جسر الشمبان الرابط بينهم درمان وبحري
طيب واذا ما تحدثنا على التصريحات على
المستوى السياسي طبعا استمعنا الى تصريحات
قوى الحريه والتغيير
وحديثها ايضا عن تشكيل كتله مدنيه صلبه
ومتحده ضد الحرب الى اي حد هناك في ظل هذه
الاوضاع
والاشتباكات امكانيه للتواصل بين القوى
المختلفه في المكون المدني للتوصل لذلك هل
من حراك تتلمسونه سالم
نعم ليس هناك اي حراك يتم تلمسه الان
سياسيا في هذه اللحظات ولكن كل الذي يمكن
ان يتلمس الان هي موضوع الاوضاع الانسانيه
وكيفيه حصول المواطنين على احتياجاتهم
نتحدث عن الاحتياجات الضروريه بكل تاكيد
موضوع المياه وكذلك موضوع الصحه نتعلق
بالمستشفيات وكذلك ايصال الدعم المستشفيات
واصول الكادر الطبيه لها كذلك كل هذه
الامور هي التي ينظر اليها المواقع في هذه
اللحظات وهي بالنسبه له هي الهمه الاول
الان سياسيا يمكن ان تنشط هذه الافكار
السياسيه بعد ان يصل الطرفين بعد ذلك الى
هدنه حقيقيه تطبق على ارض الواقع هذه
واحده او ان
يقوم الجيش السوداني بالسيطره مباشره على
هذه الاشياء وبعد ذلك يصبح هو السلطه لذلك
يمكن بعد ذلك ان يكون هنالك حديث سياسي
واضح عندما نت حدث عن الهدنه وخاصه
الجديده وتمديدها وقضيه ان تكون خلال فتره
العيد او ربما بعد ذلك الدعم السريع اكدت
انها مستعده لهذه الهدنه هل علينا ان
ننتظر اعلان رسمي من الجيش السوداني او لا
عندما يعلن
الدعم السريع يعني ذلك ان هناك تدخلات
وهناك قبول من كافه الاطراف
نعم القوات المسلحه السودانيه بالنظر الى
الهدومات السابقه كلها كانت دائما ترحب
بهذه الهدنه لم تاتي هدنه ويرفضها الجيش
السوداني على الاطلاق عاده ما كان يعلن
موافقته على هذه الهدنه فلا اظن ان الجيش
الاسلامي يمكن ان يرفض هذا اعتقاد فقط انه
يرفض هذه الهدنه ربما يوافق على هذه
الهدنه سابقاتها كذلك
الان من الجيش حول هذه النقطه تحديدا
او فيها كذلك نعم طيب سؤال اخير فيما
يتعلق بوضع الصحفيين سالم
واريحيه التحرك هل لك ان تعطينا صوره عما
تعانوه
وما هو متوفر لديكم الان سالم كصحفيين
نعم هناك اشكاليات معقده ومرتبطه ببعضها
البعض بالنسبه للصحفيين وعملهم الميداني
الاشكاليه الاولى في التنقل نخسرها صعوبه
في التنقل بحساب ان هذه الطرق يعني في
غالبها ليست امنه تنتشر فيها مجموعه
القوات القوات الدعم السريع وايضا
يحسب المواطنون او يدونون الكثير من
الانتهاكات كذلك على هذه القوات لكن
الصحفي كان الاولى ان يذهب يكون لديه حريه
للحركه اولا ثانيا
الاليات الحركه نفسها الان لا يوجد وقود
في معظم
السكنيه في الخرطوم في معظم المناطق
القريبه حتى حتى نكون اكثر
القريبه من الخرطوم لا يوجد فيها وقود
الحركه لذلك يقول هذه الامور تعقد مساله
رصد الاحداث
رؤيه كتابه القصص عنها
وروايتها بعد ذلك
لعامه الناس ووضعها في وسائل التواصل او
حتى في احدى القنوات الرسميه هذه الامور
تعقب جدا من العمل الان وهي تحدي حقيقه
خاصه امر التحرك وامر الامر الثاني هو
موضوع امن الصحفي نفسه القوائل القناوه
عذرا القنوات الرسميه من يسيطر عليها الان
بشكل كامل وهل من قنوات خاصه لا زالت تعمل
الان
نعمل الاعلام المحلي منذ اندلاع هذه
الازمه اذا كنا نتحدث عن القنوات تحديدا
التلفزيونيه في معظمها يصعب على الكوادر
الوصول اليها لذلك هي شبه متوقفه عن العمل
عدا انها تعتمد على الارشيف وما كان مسجلا
في هذه القنوات غالب هذه القنوات الان لا
تعمل
لايف او مباشر
وتوقفت عن اداء مهامها نسبه لتوقف الحركه
وكذلك انعدام الامن كذلك ذات السببين في
معظم هذه القنوات او كلها استطيع ان اقول
لا توجد الان السودانيه ناقله للاحداث من
المباشر وحتى هناك صعوبه ايضا في مساله
التصوير كذلك صعوبه في التنقل والتامين
على من يصور كل هذه الامور هي معقده
وللمواطن العادي اذا ما توفر له امكانيه
الخروج من مكان الى اخر هل المواد
الغذائيه مت او في نقص
هناك نقص في بعض المواد الغذائيه بدات
يعني تنفذ سلع رئيسيه وضروريه
بدات تنفذ من الاماكن التي يمكن ان يشتري
منها المواطن وهذا الامر ايضا لنكن اكثر
دقه هو محدود في احياء القريبه كلها من
اماكن النزاع وكل الاماكن التي بالقرب
منها اشتباكات نجد هذا الامر واضحا لكن
اذا ابتعدنا قليلا من الاماكن التي توجد
فيها الاشتباكات وربما يكون الامر اسهل
الى حد ما اسهل للوصول الى المواد
الغذائيه ولتوفرها ولكن هل من اموال متوفر
للناس خاصه للفقراء وهؤلاء الذين يعملون
باليوميه كما يقال
مشكله جديده ان كثير من المواطنين
السودانيين اصلا يعتمدون في موضوع الاموال
على تطبيق
بنكك وقد توقف هذا التطبيق منذ الامس حتى
هذه اللحظه هذا التطبيق لا يعمل وحتى هناك
في وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي يقود حمله من
حمله هاشتاق لموضوع اعاده هذا التطبيق
للعمل لان جل اموالهم في هذا التطبيق في
بنك الخرطوم من اجل التعامل بها او حتى
التحويل من ولايه الى ولايه او من مدينه
الى مدينه بالنسبه للذين ابتعدوا عن اهلهم
او ليسوا بالقرب منهم كذلك فتوقف هذا
التطبيق ايضا الان يشكل واحده من الامور
التي تشل الحركه الاقتصاديه في هذه
اللحظات
من باريس السيد محمد الاسباط الكاتب
الصحفي كنت قد اشرت الى نقطه تتعلق
بالمكون المدني نتحدث القوه الحريه
والتغيير تتحدث عن انه الحل حل هذه الازمه
طبعا مرهون بتشكيل كتله مدنيه صلبه ومتحده
ضد الحرب هل يمكن لهذه الحرب ان ترمم
الانشقاقات اذا مصحه تعبير بين المكون
المدني التي لاحظناها خلال عمليه
توقيع الاتفاق الايطالي او لا
هو هو فعلا بدات بدات بدات نواه هذه
الكتله المدنيه الصلبه
في يوم الاثنين تم اصدار بيان
وقعت عليه لجان المقاومه
ومنظمات مهنيه
واحزاب من قوى الحريه والتغيير المجلس
المركزي
ومنظمات فئويه
وصدر بيان اخر يوم الثلاثاء اتسعت دائره
المشاركين في هذا البيان
يعني متوقع ان يصدر بيان ثالث اليوم حسب
بعض التسريبات او بعض احاديث الفاعلين في
هذا في هذا الاطار من متوقع ان يكون هنالك
اعلان
عن هذه الكتله التي ستضم ليان المقاومه
وتضم جزء من قوه الحريه والتغيير هنالك
خلاف حول ان هل ستشارك الحريه والتغيير
المركزي ككتله ام كاحزاب وتم يبدو انه تم
حل المشكله مؤخرا بان التوقيع يكون عن
طريق احزاب لان البيانين السابقين كان
هنالك حزب الامه موقعه لحاله وحزب
التجمع الاتحادي وقع لحاله والمعتبر
السوداني وقع على حاله ويتوقع ان يعني ان
تستمر الكتله وان اتوقع ان يصدر بيان يحدد
يعني مكونات
هذه الجبهه المدنيه واهدافها ووسائلها
وقاياتها وتبنيها
لوقف الحرب السودانيين عموما بداوا بداوا
في في حملات العمل المدني
للملاحظه الحرب ستبدا غدا الجمعه تقريبا
في 10 مدن حول العالم اشهرها واشنطن
نيويورك
ولندن وستكون يوم السبت والاحد كذلك هنالك
وقفات امام البرلمانات وراسات الوزراء
ووزاره الخارجيه في هذه الدول تطالب
بممارسه مزيد من الضغط على قائديه
الانقلاب قائد الانقلاب ونائبه لوقف الحرب
المدني بدا يعني ينتعش
لما قيل من عقوبات ايضا الولايات المتحده
تنظر في فرضها على بعض القيادات العسكريه
على كل ما ابقى معي سيد محمد دعنا نتحدث
بالتفصيل عن حرب السلطه او عن الجنرلين
كما باتت توصف حيث شارفت الحرب يومها
الخامس شارف هذا اليوم على الانتهاء وفيما
الاشتباكات تتواصل تتزايد المخاوف من توسع
رقعه النزاع ليدق اسوار الدول المجاوره
وايضا ان يزعزع امنها دعونا نتابع
حرب الازقه والشوارع معديه وقد تتسرب شيئا
فشيئا لحاره مجاوره واخرت لها طالما ان
الجنراللين سقطا بمحظور الاقتتال الداخلي
فخ اوقع بدول محيطه منذ سنوات انها شخص
اقتصادها وافقر شعوبها
السودان لاحقه بالركب ولم يفوته القطار
دوله شلها غياب المركزيه السياسيه
والعسكريه كما جيرانها ليبيا وسوريا
ولبنان حيث يفترض انها دول مستقله تتمتع
بالسياده وحق تقرير المصير اي دول ديجيوري
وفق القانون الدولي لكنها وجدت نفسها على
الجانب الاخر من القائمه دول مسلوبه
القرار ومهمشه بحكم الواقع او دفاكتو
هذه الفوضى الداخليه مرميه على حافه
التوسع بحكم موقع السودان الجيو السياسي
بالغ الاهميه فالوضع السوداني يهدد بنشر
الفوضى في دول مجاوره وعيسى في بعضها فساد
بالاصل ارتريا واثيوبيا من الشرق تشاد
وليبيا من الغرب وصولا الى مصر من الجهه
الشماليه فمن شان اي اضطراب في السودان ان
يزعزع امنها القومي ويضر بحصصها المائيه
مع سعي اثيوبيا لتعبئه سد النهضه السودان
يطل كذلك على البحر الاحمر الذي يربط اهم
ممرين بحريين هما باب المندب وقناه السويس
ما يزيد مغريات الدوله الذهبيه الكثيره في
عيون دول كبرى بينها روسيا وتركيا فحلم
القاعده البحريه هناك تتشاركه الدولتان
حرب الجنرالين تمتلك الخلطه الناجحه
والسريعه للحرب الاهليه للاشتباكات طويله
الامد وتوزعها على مساحات واسعه وامكانيه
انزلاق الحركات المسلحه الاخرى الى المشهد
اما الحل السياسي المامول فبايد ليست
متوفره حاليا بل ممدوده الى اوكرانيا
وتايوان حل لن يكون مغيرا عن سابقه
الخجوله قبل اندلاع حرب اللا منتصر اي
خساره الطرفين وانتقال القياده لطرف ثالث
سيد محمد اعود اليك للحديث عما يحدث على
الارض كنا تحدثنا عن تدخلات اقليبيه
وغيرها كثير من المراقبين كانوا يتحدثون
ايضا عن حرب اهليه شرسه يمكن لها ان تنفجر
في اي لحظه ما هي النقطه الفاصله التي
يمكن لها ان تحرك من لم يتحرك الان
هو الحرب عندما تبدا لا احد يعني
يتنبا بمالاتها ولكن من خلال الواقع من
خلال التجربه من خلال تجارب البشر والحروب
ان الحرب مثل هذه الحرب حرب بين حرب مثل
حرب البرهان وحميدتي من المتوقع ان ما ان
تطاولت الحرب ان تتحول الى حرب اهليه يعني
تاكل الاخضر واليابس وتضع السودان يعني
الوجود السوداني تضعه على الحافه سيصبح
السودان امام سؤال ان يكون او لا يكون
ولكن
اذا تدخل العقلاء اذا حدثت يعني اي اي
حاله اختراق في هذه الازمه وتم يعني
اطلاقنا طويله الامد وعقبها جلوس الفرقاء
الى طاوله التفاوض يمكن ان يضع حد لهذه
الحرب ولكن
المعطيات التي دفعت كل كلا من الرجلين
لخوض هذه الحرب هي
معطيات التحكم والسيطره وبالتالي الشهيه
ستظل مفتوحه لكلا الجنرلين حتى ان يبلغ
قاعدته ولكن هنالك ايضا عوائق تحول دون
بلوغ اي من الجدررين غاياته وهي ان اي
واحد منهما يحلم او يمني النفس بدراسه حكم
المعزول عمر البشير وحكم السودان بقوه
السلاح القاهره وبالتالي لا يرغب اي منهما
في الاصطدام بالمجتمع الدولي لا يرغب اي
منهما في الاستيطان بدول الاقليم لا يرغب
اي من هو بت سمعته ولا يرغب اي منهما
بامتداد الحرب حتى
تتحول الى حرب اهليه لانه بكل تاكيد
وببساطه شديده جدا ستجلب الرجلين الى
المحاكم الدوليه لانه اصلا الرجلان يعني
لديهما سجل بشع في الجرائم ضد الانسانيه
والجرائم حرب في دارفور سواء كان قائد
الانقلاب البرهان عندما كان مشرفا على
القوات العسكريه وشكل العسكريه في
دارفورته
هذه الفتره وهذا يدفعني للتساؤل عن دارفور
وان كانت هي النقطه الرئيسيه التي يمكن
لها ان تتحرك لتشعل هذه الحرب الاهليه
وتمتد الى مناطق اخرى
مدثر هل تتلمسون من خلال التصريحات لانه
سمعنا الى تصريحات حاكم دارفور يقول فيها
ان لم يستطع الجيش السيطره على الارض فس
فنحن سنتحرك وبالتالي هل تستشعرون تتلمسون
من تصريحات مناطق مختلفه انه ممكن ان تدخل
جهات جديده على المشهد او لا
يعني من خلال التصريحات التي
اطلقها كل من قائد الدعم السريع وقائد
الجيش في هذا اليوم الى بعض وسائل الاعلام
تحدث الرجلان عن
امكانيه تمديد الهدنه
[موسيقى]
صوره واضحه الدعم السريع محمد حمدان
الامكانيه المهله الى خلال عطله ولكن في
تصريحات تاليه لهذه لهذه التصريحات تحدث
القائد الجيش عن ان مساله الهدنه في ظل
سيطره القوات الدعم السريع على معظم
المداخل والمخارج
المدينه الاول العاصمه يصعب تطبيق هذه
الهدنه ووضع بعض الشروق في هذه الهدنه
بينما اريد لها الاستمرار اذا هناك هناك
تنازلات في هذه الحجه التي كانت في اليوم
الاول والثاني الان كل طرف منهم يريد ان
يقضي على الاخر هذه هذه التنازلات التي
بدات في هذه التصريحات تشير الى ان هناك
امكانيه
الجلوس وامكانيه وقف اطلاق النار امكانيه
الحوار
متابع طبعا التطورات مدثر
نعم سنتابع التطورات ان كان على الارض او
من خلال التصريحات ولكن اسمح لي انضم الي
الان المتحدث باسم وزاره الصحه في السودان
محمد ابراهيم عبد الرحمن اهلا بك دكتور
اسمح لي ان ابدا بالحديث عن تصريحات منظمه
الصحه العالميه الى اي حد الارقام
ونقلها لما يحدث في السودان يعكس الواقع
هل من تنسيق فيما بينكم وبالتالي انتم
المصدر ام ماذا
بسم الله
والعافيه الرحمه والمغفره الذين فاضت
ارواحهم الطاهره الى باقيها نتيجه الاحداث
في السودان وتحيه عمركم للقطاع الصحي
العريض الذي ما زال يقدم الخدمات
التمريضيه والصحيه الطبيه في ظل الظروف
منظمه الصحه العالميه انا متحدث باسم
وزاره الصحه واولئيه الخرطوم يعني كل
الارقام التي اتحدث عنها هي هي خاصه
بولايه خرطوم فقط واذا تصح العالميه تتحدث
عن الارقام في جميع ولايات السودان وليس
هنالك اختلاف كثير في الالغام يعني
لانه الارقام الذي هي ارقام تراكميه ل 18
ولايه ونتحدث طيب خبرنا عن ولايه الخرطوم
اعطينا الارقام المختصه بذلك وعن الوضع
الصحي بهذا الاطار
[موسيقى]
ماشي في تقدم احسن من الايام الاولى
نتيجه الشغل المكثف للجهاز الاختصاص
واللجنه المركزيه لطوارئ المستشفيات على
المستويين الوزاره الاتحاديه ولايه
الخرطوم
واداره شان الولايه عدد المصابين في
الخمسه ايام السابقه اللي هو منذ 15 وحتى
فجر اليوم
1722 مصاب واتوا الى الاستشفاف في
مستشفيات الولايه البالغ عددها 133 مستشفى
43 مستشفى بالغطاء العام 81 مستشفي القطاع
الخاص مجمل الوفيات
سجلت في المستشفى
46 في الغطاء العام
وتسعه وخمسين في القطاع الخاص
[موسيقى]
هنالك 31 حاله
في غرف الانعاش والعنايه المكثفه 13 في
مستشفيات الغطاء العام 2018 يمسك القطعه
الخاص مراكز الكلى غسيل الكلى من 30 مركز
كانت تعمل الان تعمل 24 مركز تغطي الخدمه
بالنسبه لمرضى الكلى والبادر عددهم 3,5
هنالك مراكز تقدم الخدمات
من الرعايه الصحيه الاوليه على المستوى
الاولي في في جميع المحليات الولايه التي
تعمل الان لحد صبيحه اليوم 41 مركز صحي
متوزعي على على ارتفاع المحليات تقدم
الخدمات الرعايه الصحيه على المستوى الاول
سيدي عندما المخزون من الدم مطمن جدا
ومخزون الادويه والمستهلكات مطمن جدا حتى
تاريخ اليوم
هذه ارقام ولايه الخرطوم قبل ان تكمل لانه
ذكرت انه في 133 مستشفى عامل كل
المستشفيات عامله ام توقفت عن العمل لانه
بحسب ما افهم تصريحات سابقه انه في مناطق
معينه مناطق الاشتباك خرجت المستشفيات عن
الخدمه فيها
بطبيعه الحل اذا في حرب في منطقه لحمايه
ارواح المدنيين المقدمين الخدمه والمرضى
لازم انه
الوزاره تخليهم عشان ما يعرضوا لاصابه في
هذه المناطق ما في مريض
عدد مستشفيات الولايات الخرطوم 133
منها مستشفيات عامه و81
التي تقدم الخدمه حتى اللحظه 103 مستشفى
يعني
خارجه عن الخدمه حجم هذه المستشفيات وحجم
الاستيعاب وبالتالي بالمقابل 103 مستشفيات
الاخرى هل هي قادره على
استيعاب من لا يستطيعون حصول الحصول على
الخدمه من 30 مستشفى الاخرى
المسلسلات المتوقفه تم توقيفها
حفاظا على ارواح المدنيين فيها ورحلت هذه
المسلسلات الى مستشفيات البديله الامنه في
المحليات الاخرى
لتقديم الخدمات الصحيه وحال توفر الامس
ترجع المستشفيات لتقديم الخدمات المسيفات
التي تقدم الخدمه الان عافيه جدا لتقديم
الخدمات اذا اننا في ولايه الخرطوم نستهلك
فقط في وضع السلم 30% من المقدره
الاستعابيه للمستشفيات
وبالتالي خروج هذه المسيفات لا يؤثر كثيرا
على تقديم الخدمات صحيح في ظل الازمه
الحاليه خاصه وان الترددات الان تساوي
اثنين لاربعه من الترددات الوضع الطبيعي
الان صفات تقتبل من 300 الى 400 حاله في
اليوم
مقارنه بعشر الف وخمستاش حاله في وضع
السين في اليوم طيب الكلام جميل جدا الذي
ذكرته ولكنه يتناقض بعد الشيء مع تصريحات
سابقه تتعلق بانه ليس هناك من وقود كافن
ايضا بعض الادويه ليست متوفره لا امكانيه
للوصول الى المخازن للحصول على الاحتياجات
والاجهزه المطلوبه
نحن الان ندير هذا الشان من باداره الازمه
اداره الازمه تختلف قطعا الوضع ما طبيعي
كما كان في السلم يعني حصل اليوم الثاني
واليوم الثالث من الازمه بعد التعثر في
الحصول على الوقود نتيجه الانقطاع
الكهرباء اكثر من 24 ساعه
في تمت اداره هذا اداره هذه الازمه بتوفير
الوقود لجميع المستشفيات اللي كانت عامله
في قطاعات القطاعات الكبرى للولايه اللي
هي بتاع بحر ام درمان الخرطوم وعدينا
الازمه بتاعه قطاعات الكهرباء يعني
الامراض المزمنه الان على قدم الوثائق
الجهاز وتفصيله
في ظل هذه الامه الامراض المزمنه جدا
الوضع مستقر جدا
افتكر ما في جهه غيرنا عندها المعلومات
الموثقه غير وزاره الصحه
مركز الطوارئ كان يتحدث عن بعض المعوقات
خاصه فيما يتعلق ليس فقط بالوقود كما ذكرت
والادويه ولكن ايضا حتى في الوصول الى بعض
المناطق
واعطاء المساعده الطبيه
والتحرك على الارض بالنهايه من قبل
الاسعافات الاولانيه هذه المعضله كانت في
اليوم الاول يوم 15 و16
تم تنفيذ هذا الموضوع في الغرفه المركزيه
الكبرى دفاع كل المعنيين بالامر الان تم
السماح لحريه الحركه بالنسبه للاسعاف
صباح له بعبور الجسور كان لا يعبر الجسور
الرابطه بين البحري والخرطوم وذلك للدواعى
الامنيه حسب ما فادونه الان هذا الامر
ديليا تماما اصبح الاسعاف له كافه
الصلاحيات في مرور الحركه ولكن حتى الان
لم نحتاج الى عبور الكباري لانه تم توزيع
المستشفيات بالمحليات
دون قطع جسر لحفظ الامان لحتى سيقين
الاسعاف وكذلك ماذا تقول بالتصريحات
الجغرافي للمستشفيات والمناطق
تودي الخدمه الى الان لم تجد شكوى بانه
اسعاف منعليه او حوده مريض لنقله الى
مستشفى لقطع الجسور ماذا تقول في
التصريحات السابقه التي تحدثت عن انه
الارقام التي نراها الان لا تضم من يمكن
ان يكونوا في اماكن الاشتباك حيث لا
تستطيع في مناطق الاشتباك ليس في رقعه
الاشتباك ولكن المناطق المحيطه
هذه الارقام فقط الارقام التي وصلت الى
المستشفى
ماذا تتوقعون فيما يتعلق
هل لديكم رصد او معلومات نعم تفضل وبعد
مخاطبه الجهاز وتصيلها الان
سمحت لجهاز
ونقل الجثث الى المشارف حسب
حسب سياسات واجراءات الطب العقلي طيب
دكتور محمد ماذا عن الامراض المزمنه
والحالات التي تحتاج الى علاج يومي كيف
يتم التعامل معها تم توجيهي الى
المستشفيات الطرفيه والمستشفيات المحليه
العامله
جميع هذه المسيفات تقدم يعني نفس المستوى
تقديم الخدمات لان المستوى الثاني والثالث
والرابع وكل المصيفات التي تم تفريغها
لانها غير امنه تم ايجاد من صفات البديله
لها التي تقدم نفسك
الى اي حد كانت الهدنه عامل مساعد لكم
للتقدم في تقديم الرعايه الصحيه كما تظهر
من خلال تصريحاتك
تبديل الكوادر التي انهكت بالعمل طوال
الفتره من 15 وحتى ينتظر دون تبديل
الكوادر وتغييرهم يعني
وعبركم جميع الكوادر الصحيه الذين يعني
كانوا يعملون
وهل المخازن تكفي ولمتى
من مخزون ان كان من الاجهزه او الادويه
وغيره
نحن المخزون الان كافي انا كما تحدث
يساوي 2% من
يعني المخزون الان موجود في المستشفيات
يكفي
الفتره التي يكفيها هذا المخزون سيدي لانه
انتم بفتره اشتباكات وازمه يعني مش بالوضع
الطبيعي
الان المخزون كافي مع اننا فيه مع ان في
اشكال يعني متى ما نقصت اي مستشفى رفعت
لنا امر بانه في المخزون عندنا مستودعات
الامدادات الطبيه في الخرطوم والدوله
الدائري في بحري طيب جميل
ان يكون
الوضع رحمان المتحدث باسم وزاره الصحه في
السودان شكرا جزيلا لك
التغطيه لهذه الساعه انتهت نشكر ضيوفنا من
جنوب الخرطوم كان معنا صحفي مدثر محمد
احمد وطبعا نشكر المراسلينا الكاتب الصحفي
ايضا محمد الاسباط على راس الساعه ريمبو
قمرا واستمرار لهذه التغطيه حول التطورات
في السودان مشاهدينا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات